welcome back okay so now we have a
coordinate transformation T that makes
our controllability and observability
crimeans equal and diagonal remember the
controllability and observability Graham
Ian's quantify in this very big high
dimensional system which directions are
most controllable and most observable
and least controllable and least
observable okay so very useful geometric
quantities these are square matrices the
size of n by n where n is the dimension
of X and we showed last time that there
is a coordinate transformation T into
these new Z coordinates where my Grammie
ins are balanced so these z coordinates
are somehow good coordinates that are
jointly controllable and observable
that's very interesting okay now what
we're going to use right now this T
matrix is a big square and by n
invertible matrix and so we don't
actually get any savings by writing
things in Z coordinates it's just a
better coordinate system where the
inputs and outputs are more balanced
okay what more did though in 1981 is he
essentially used these coordinates the Z
coordinates to get a reduced order model
so let's let's write this this is a
reduced order model by essentially just
picking the top most controllable and
observable directions in Z and throwing
away all of the rest okay so remember
kind of the picture here is we have this
tall X vector this might be like a
million dimensional X vector super big
we're going to say that that equals T
times Z okay so T is this big square
matrix it's a coordinate transformation
or a change of basis if you like and z
is another tall tall vector Z okay this
equals T times Z but what is really
interesting about hierarchically
ordering our controllability and
observability directions or modes and
these Z coordinates is that the first
variable Z 1 is more important than the
second variable Z 2 that's more
important than Z 3 than Z 4 then Z 5 so
if I decided at any
good point I can only afford four
variables I would keep the first four Z
variables and I'd throw everything else
away and that's a principled way of
getting a truncation so I'm gonna draw
this in another color here what I could
do is I could only keep the first our
let's call our our reduced state
dimension X our maybe our equals 5 or 10
I only keep the first 5 or 10 columns of
T and the first 5 or 10 entries of Z and
what I do is I just give that a new name
I call that sy sy and X tilde okay
so this is it's taken a long build up
okay but what we've done is essentially
found a principled approach to finding
good reduced coordinates X tilde these
are only a few numbers to describe the
dominant patterns in a system in terms
of the first are columns of this
balancing transformation team that's all
there is okay we picked the first our
columns sigh of this big trip balancing
transformation T and those correspond to
the state X tilde which are the first
most controllable and observable states
in these new coordinate system in this
very simple toy example this pink
ellipsoid you know basically this first
Direction is quantifiably more important
for the dynamics than the second
direction so if I was going to truncate
I'd pick everything I'd project the
dynamics into that direction okay
that's what balance truncation is this
step here everything so far has been
just balancing dynamics with the
balancing transformation this step here
is called balanced truncation the
acronym you could call it BT that is
really what more did okay so more built
all of this infrastructure just like I
built up how the transformations apply
to Graham Ian's how you would design
this balancing transformation T but what
his ultimate goal was was finding a
reduced order model by truncating so
this is called truncation because this
everything below here and everything to
the right of here is truncated literally
we throw that all away and we only
consider
the dominant controllable and observable
subspace okay
that's what more did that's called
balance truncation super-powerful used
everywhere I mean this is a go-to model
reduction technique if you have a linear
model you can get a reduced order model
using balance truncation in MATLAB
there's a bunch of built in MATLAB
command commands the bowel reel will get
this balance realization you can give it
a truncate option I'll show you all of
those in a little bit and we'll code up
something to you know to try these out
on an example but what I want to show
you now is essentially what happens
remember we could write our coordinate
system from x coordinates to Z
coordinates now what I want to do is I
want to carefully write down what
happens if I split this into T and then
everything I'm going to throw away okay
so this is going to be kind of important
and this is really a mathematical
exercise to convince ourselves that the
reduced order model works and is
principled and that we can get one just
by keeping these first our columns of T
so I'm gonna have to make some
definitions okay so I'm gonna say that
my Big T is equal to the first our
columns
okay I'm gonna go Greek on you here all
of this stuff I'm keeping is gonna be
Greek and all the stuff I'm throwing
away is going to be not Greek okay so
side are the the columns I'm keeping and
the stuff that I'm truncating I'm gonna
call Tisa little T that little T stands
for truncate I'm going to throw that
stuff away okay so I'm segmenting my
matrix into T truncate and Sai I'm also
going to introduce a matrix s equals T
inverse remember this was an invertible
matrix under some reasonable assumptions
all this works out and I'm going to say
that s this s matrix I'm gonna write
that in terms of again I'm gonna keep
the first R rows I'm gonna call that V
complex conjugate transpose just so the
dimensions work out and s truncates okay
these are both big square matrices
this is the inverse of TS as the inverse
of T I'm going to keep the first are
columns of T and the first are rows of s
and I'm going to name them sy and Phi
transpose don't get you hung up on the
naming just to Greek letters this is all
I'm keeping and what I want to see is
when I write this coordinate
transformation to Z coordinates and I
throw away all but the first R
components and X tilde what stays and
what goes in the dynamics ok so we're
just gonna we're gonna write this as the
following so DDT hope everyone's ready
this is gonna be some math DDT of Z and
remember what are we gonna split Z up
into we're gonna split Z up into the
stuff we're keeping X tilde that's my
reduced order model this might only be
five or ten states I'm gonna keep it in
to that and then I'm gonna call
everything I'm going to throw away Z
truncate so Big Z my million dimensional
state maybe there's ten variables I care
about the ten most controllable and
observable and then the other you know
nearly a million things I'm gonna throw
away
okay so Z truncate is that bottom stuff
down there and what this is going to
equal if I split all this stuff up just
kind of work with me here if I multiply
remember in the Z coordinates my
dynamics are T inverse a T so I'm going
to take T inverse which is s times a
times T so this a matrix should be T
inverse a T which equals s a T okay yes
I T and so what I end up getting here is
if I basically just multiply this and
this and this and this times this a
matrix and then I try to keep track of
where everything lands I'm gonna get a
fee star a sigh I'm going to get a feast
are a all the stuff I'm truncating t
truncate I'm gonna get an s truncate a
sigh and I'm going to get an s truncate
a
truncates okay so this is kind of I'm
gonna get this big matrix the same size
as a this is an N by n matrix but I can
kind of keep track of the different r by
r blocks and n minus r by n minus our
blocks and stuff like that okay and this
is times my state x tilde and z truncate
all the stuff I don't care about and now
I have to keep track of what happens to
my B matrix what does be B is just T
inverse B which equals s times B okay
and so I can keep track of what happens
in my B matrix as there's a fee star
component B and there's all the stuff
I'm going to truncate all of this Esty
Esty times B okay and then finally I can
also look at what happens on my
measurements y equals okay see what was
C C was equal to T in it was equal to C
times T okay and C times T there is a
component which is C sigh and C times
everything I'm going to truncate into
you okay so I hope you're following all
I'm doing here is basically writing what
it would happen if I change to Z
coordinates but I'm keeping very careful
track of what happens to the first our
variables and all of the stuff I'm going
to truncate in terms of the different
columns and rows of T and it's inverse s
and notice that everything except the
first R by R block so the first R by R
Block is only in terms of Greek letters
fee and sy sy and fee and everything
else
that has something in terms of a
truncated variable is going to have one
of these s T's or tt's and we're going
to just chop all of that stuff off
notice that it's not a perfect it's not
this is not a perfect model if I just
throw away all of my Z T because X tilde
does in fact depend on Z T but we're
gonna make that assumption anyway and
we're just gonna chop this stuff off so
the basic idea now is I'm gonna get D DT
of X tilde is approximate
equal to this thing five-star a sy+
times X tilde sorry plus five star B u
and y is going to equal to C times sigh
X tilde and this is my reduced order
model this is the thing we've been
trying to build towards for the last you
know five videos or so is this is the
dynamical system in my reduced state X
tilde where all I'm doing is I'm taking
this coordinate transformation that
balances my Grammie ins and I'm just
chopping it off at some point and only
keeping the first R components this is
the projection onto the first our most
controllable and observable subspace of
my dynamics and this is a little R by r
matrix you know this thing is you know
are tall and are wide so this is really
really nice okay this is a fast reduced
order model it's easy to simulate it
captures most of the input-output energy
and it's it's useful for for control for
fast low latency control okay so that's
that's the big picture this is balance
truncation if you have a B and C you can
go through all of these procedures you
can compute the crimeans you can compute
their eigenvectors you can scale those
eigenvectors to get t and s and then you
can keep the first R columns and rows
and obtain a reduced order model that in
some sense is pretty good at capturing
input to output dynamics okay that's
what it's designed for
so that is balance truncation in a
nutshell you should be asking yourself
some questions okay I said that this
would work for a million or a billion
dimensional state vector X none of what
I told you actually works for a million
or a billion dimensional state vector
because all of this relies on me being
able to build these graeme ins and
compute their eigenvectors and
eigenvalues okay that's not very
reasonable computing the granion of a
million dimensional state space system
is very expensive okay maybe you can do
it on a really really big computer but
you can't do it easily and you can't do
it on a billion dimensional
okay so and then computing that's
eigenvectors is also really hard so all
of this works really well on thousand or
10,000 dimensional systems but it's
pretty ugly when it scales to million or
billion dimensional systems that we
actually want to work on so we should
really be thinking about how do we
approximate these from data okay all of
this was just math on matrices what
we're gonna talk about next and this is
balanced P OD and there's major
contributions by Karen Wilcox and also
by Clancy Raleigh in essentially using
data-driven approaches to approximate
these transformations SCI and fee that's
scale to much much larger systems
million billion dimensional systems so
that's what we're gonna talk about next
is essentially how do you do this at
scale how do you take Moore's balance
truncation and scale it up to million or
billion dimensional systems where I
never really want to actually build a
Grammy in so a data-driven way of
approximating these transformations
okay that's coming up and that's
actually going to be directly useful
thank you